all right April April 9th good to be
here with you guys let's go
that's it
there you go that's the original right
there
[Music]
you gotta get up
if you if they throw in lemons at you
[Music]
make lemon candy bruh alright there we
are man that's Spencer Jacob growl band
and that is celebrate thank you very
much we have Nick will be back with us
in studio he's just kicking us off and
he's checking out now see he'll be back
in a little bit I want to thank you guys
for being here with me on this past
weekend it is April 9th s April 9th oh
man listen what's what's going on let's
go I just got back from Tampa and I
don't know if you've ever been to Tampa
but Tampa is the kind of place where
first of all it's a bunch of people that
wanted to be pirates I think and then
pirating went out of business so
suddenly it's you got a lot of people
that suddenly just straight-up
landlocked and the zoning is insane you
will have a dental you'll have a place
where you get dental and then next door
strip club you know but strip club will
also have you know maybe they'll do you
know all beef patties
out the back so we you know like you
everything is possible and that's one
thing I really enjoyed about it you know
you could get you get a used car and
prosthetic limb same place because the
zoning is just I don't know who did the
zoning you know I don't know who did the
commercial residential zoning you know
you'll have six homeless people live in
you know legally living right in a
supermarket and they kind of you know
they out there in the frozen foods and
they all wearing you know parkas and
[ __ ] and you trying to get some fish you
know you're just trying to get some MA
some fish sticks or you know them
breaded chicken Phillips and they are
trying to hit you up for a dollar you
open that frozen food section and ba-bam
you know soil irani pops out you know
soil irani pops out with that dirty hand
he kind of kept that book off you and
all you trying to get is a bag of those
afro
and carb hitters you know we're frozen
bass pieces or whatever they're serving
you know fish sticks but Yemen they got
that wild zoning you know you get used
car and prosthetic limb so you got a
Ford Fiesta with [ __ ] new you know you
know new kneecaps in the back and that's
Tampa anything is possible in Tampa you
know it's like that and they have crime
but they don't it's a it's kind of
everywhere a little bit and you know I
like I like a city that have some crime
because you know what you know what when
a city has crime you know what's better
the food I'll tell you that even a
peanut butter and jelly sandwich down
there in New Orleans tastes better
because you know somebody's getting
popped off two or three blocks away so
your taste buds you know they're they
know that this is you know this is life
or death situation they know that even
if you just got a bowl of gazpacho that
this [ __ ] could be your last meal so
your taste buds they show up you know
they tuxedo up to the top of your tongue
and they're ready to really embrace
whatever is going on you know if you're
eating somewhere you know you're eating
down there in Boca Raton or you're
eating over in damn you know some other
city or something you know some fancy
place you're eating over in Los Angeles
you're eating over in where's another
place that's fancy
oh Martha's Vineyard then you you know
you could probably barely even taste you
know you're not alive but somebody give
you a you know a kettle full of of
gazpacho in South Chicago that's that's
the life or death dining food tastes
better in cities where the crime rate is
higher and I'll say that to the end of
time because something there's just
something it's just something about you
know when somebody's just around the
corner trying to set you off with a
knife it just you know it adds a little
bit more mystique to a pork chop it
really does and look I grew up
in that environment where you know you
when that dangers outside boy everything
tastes good because that might be your
last grip that might be your throat in
your bellies last grip at sustenance and
and I felt like you get a little bit of
that in Tampa you get that danger you
know there's cannons they have people
have [ __ ] cannons they're not can I
my talking cameras you'll see a couple
homeless dudes or a couple dudes who
have homes but don't mind looking
homeless and they shining up a cannon
ball at a gas station you know it's like
a [ __ ] it's you know 2018 and you out
there polishing sea balls at a [ __ ]
Citgo what's going on but that's that
pirating lifestyle it's a little bit in
the bloodstream over there in Tampa in
Tampa you find a lot of women talking on
their cell phone crossing the street
with no shoes on apparently you don't
have to have shoes in Tampa that's a
alternate you know that's optional shoes
optional you know some places that they
say you know no shirt no shoes no shoes
no shoes no service
well Tampa doesn't say that Tampa it's
just like service because some Bay you
know six out of eleven people aren't
gonna have shirt and shoes yeah I got to
the airport and I'll say this man the
airport the new worst airport in America
Tampa International Airport dude this
[ __ ] thing it took 25 minutes to get
to the rental car place and now I was
cruising now I didn't have to wait in
line is you got to go all the up these
escalators down these escalators you got
to take a tram you got to take another
tram a lot of senior citizens mark my
words
a lot of senior citizens gonna die at TP
a Tampa International Airport because
they're not thinking about humans I mean
if you want to drop off a rental car
[ __ ] and you're leaving on Friday you
better you better show up on Thursday
morning or you will not get to the
actual you won't get to your gate
[ __ ] was dangerous man it was real it
got real gameofthrones he over there
around the around the TSA area but you
know I'm complaining look I mean I'm not
complaining I'm celebrating the city you
know I had some barbecue and I said you
know that was pretty good
what else did I see over there saw some
big old you know they got them cancer
tits out there in Tampa you get a lot of
sunburned breast meat so they got them
straight-up [ __ ] cancer front bags
out there you know you see them some
girl rocking them [ __ ] them D cups
you know but two-thirds of the cup is
probably melanoma and you see them
rocking that and I'm not condoning
breast cancer I'm not wishing upon that
on anybody even anybody that don't have
breasts but you'll see ladies out there
damn boy they hey you know they've tried
they wearing shoes that match with their
you know with their burn up chest skin
lady look like in the chest sometime
right between them tits they look like
some of these ladies look a little bit
like have you ever had a thing of French
onion soup
and then it gets kind of if you let it
sit for too long that thing gets on the
top that little bit of layer of you know
it just gets a little bit too French on
the top and it starts it gets this
little film like that little layer of
you know soup epidermis just like that
but put it right between on the lady's
chest and throw a Winston in her jaw
throw a big win stand up in Judy's jaw
so she huffing on a Winston running with
that French onion [ __ ] tit front no
shoes does have a shirt definite service
strip clubs tacos diversity that's Tampa
you know it's a pirate's life for me and
we have the shows at a place called the
attic over there in Ybor City and and if
you haven't been a bore city as wild man
it's cool it's like has like this gay
thug it's like has a mix you know it's
real thug but then a lot of uh you know
a lot of gay men and homoerotic people
moved in and you know started making it
fancy so you have both sides of it I
remember the first time I was in Tampa
years ago this dude ran up on me and he
had a blade or something put it right
into my side he's like give me all your
money and let me hold your dick for a
second and I'm like damn this is you
know there's some new kind of crime this
that you know this that homoerotic
robbery so eventually brought us [ __ ]
ended up honestly dude jerked off into a
couple of bucks and gave him that
because I didn't want to get you know I
don't want to get any deeper into the
well sometimes if somebody asks you for
the money you give them the money
because you know what you got after that
you got the rest of your life and uh and
I had a good time over in Tampa dude I
had a good time over there in Tampa I
want to thank the Attic at Rock Brothers
man I want to thank everybody that came
out you know we sold out the shows I
mean we had three shows over there and
we sold them out and I flew over there
you know and uh and I'm you know I saw
Shawn Wayans he was working at The
Improv down the street and he's always a
little bit snooty but you know he's you
know he kind of said some nice stuff and
and we showed up over there Rock
Brothers in the Attic if you're thinking
about doing a show you're a comedian and
you want to do something a revenge in
Tampa man it's a beautiful little locale
so beach bums haddock volleyball group
that came out my boy Dom Nelson and I
met him years ago we were both doing
judging children's pageants and it was a
really kind of a weird time for me I got
caught up with this group that was you
know judging children's pageants judging
beautiful children up in Minnesota and
look I'm not like that I'm not that dude
man when I see a kid you know something
you know I think all children are mostly
beautiful sometime you get them kids
that are too you know sometime if a kid
was born too early
and Dan got off you know they don't have
a full chin or it's just like a neck
that just comes up and then makes a
u-turn and then just goes back into
their body then I'm not gonna tell you
honestly I'm not going to give that
child probably a ten out of ten if we're
you know doing judging her faith and but
this was a pageant for Miss Teen USA and
and I met my buddy Dom up there well he
ended up down in temple and they run a
thing called beach bums volleyball and I
went out there with them and it was
awesome and I don't do a lot of sand you
know stuff on the sand you know I mean
in Louisiana if you go to the beach
you're going to get [ __ ] eaten by
something or you're gonna get malaria
you know a lot of people come back from
the beach with different diseases when I
grew up you know mersa malaria people
can attack by [ __ ] sand mites they
had a buddy of mine had a [ __ ] sand
mite dug into his rib cage I mean he was
about seven or eight and lived in there
until he was about probably 18 and I
think it actually when I think about it
this boy Darin the thing came out of his
body on his 18th birthday and if that
didn't if that ain't the Lord working
dude I don't know what is but when
you've had a little mite living inside
of you you know you that [ __ ] insect
kennel you growing up your whole life
being an insect kennel and then BAM your
18th birthday you ready for new
adventures in the world and today oh
that dirty little [ __ ] that dirty
little sand mammal that little that
might comes burrowing out between your
ribs and says look man I'm gonna let you
go on and I'm gonna go my way and thank
you for the ride and that's I mean
that's beautiful man that's beautiful we
got a great show for you here today I
think you know we're gonna try something
a little different I'm gonna keep
talking about some things I got some
things I want to talk about but uh but
we're gonna try something a little bit
different I'm gonna have you know Nick
who is the producer one of the producers
we got Nick and Chris and Chris is
learning some of the ropes so we're
feeling you know figuring things out but
Nick is
come in the second half of the show and
help with the news and help with us some
calls we had a lot of great calls now
some people don't know about the hotline
man
the hotline is a thing you can use
anybody out there and if you have
something going on in your life man if
you struggling you feeling something you
know if you you know you out on the
streets or you are you in love or you're
feeling if you got a feeling then you
bring that feeling to the table and you
put it in the voice box on the hotline
you hit that voicemail and that numbers
nine eight five six six four nine five
zero three and everybody's welcome to
call that thing if you have you know
just something want to get off your
chest something you want to share
something that we can circulate out to
others and maybe get some response or
feedback for you for suggest were
suggestions from the rest of our
listeners that's an open that's an open
uh you know that thing is that things uh
gender-fluid that thing is uh you could
be anybody you could be a [ __ ] you
could be a tall lemur and be able to
communicate well long as you can hit
that hotline nine eighty five six six
four nine five zero three then we can
share some some thoughts and ideals
ideas together man we had so many great
people came out in Tampa dude I blew my
mind it blew my mind people coming up
and sharing stories people bringing
their spouses out you know it was really
inspiring you know it was really
inspiring I was exhausted when I got
home cuz I had you know I was there at
the club - one last night I caught a
6:00 a.m. flight but it was man it
really I would have been much more tired
if I hadn't been filled up in my spirit
with us a lot of positive vibes and
positive energy and and we made the most
of it over there so thank you very much
everybody in Tampa that came out what
else we had that uh that Conor McGregor
he hit up that Greyhound station and a
lot of people you know I put you know
put a video on instagrams and people
were excited about it and comment and in
this and that and people saying this
about greyhound and this about greyhound
and saying dude you don't know what
you're talking about some people well
guess what I have gone greyhound while
some of you guys were in the Cub Scouts
of the Boy Scouts and y'all were in the
woods you know making [ __ ] you know
little dog cages out of vines and you
know little damn bamboo mail boxes and
[ __ ] your boy right here was on that
greyhound and I used to take that thing
up to Natchez Mississippi and work on my
buddy's farm and and look if you you
know people upset Conor McGregor threw a
hand truck at a bus window and broke it
out well guess what man I've thought
about it that [ __ ] happens on greyhound
if you if you eat you know what happens
on greyhound
pregnancy's menthol no outlets urine
that that nyle bro if you've been on
that all night trip
the bus driver one time he first time he
dozes off he slams on the brakes when he
wakes up because he about to hit
something and that that big slam that's
when that toilet does that splash and it
breaches its bounds and next thing you
know that nyle that Greyhound nyle bruh
everybody's problems they might have a
needle in it it might have a you know a
little bitty abortion in it that thing
comes and I know that's gross but that's
the [ __ ] hound boy that is the ham
that is the sewer that is the I mean
it's what we are really you know it's
that gutter right under us and that's
that hound and this and that thing comes
rolling right down them aisle and you
better have your bags and your legs
clear man you'll catch a disease out of
that thing
you know you wake up with pinkeye in
your butthole that's the kind of I mean
that's what you can get on the hound and
things happen on there so I want to say
this if you have a greyhound Buster I
want to do a full greyhound episode
because I'm sick of people thinking that
that you know that the everything's safe
on the Hound because I'll be honest i
troll i troll the Greyhound bus to help
twitter feed and I'm on there
you know I'll troll them at night and
find people that's saying uh um excuse
me
you know mr. Sherman took us two hours
off the route to go visit his ex to go
visit a lady he met out there in Tupelo
well guess what [ __ ]
that's the hound you think [ __ ] ain't
gonna happen on grayham what do you
think you think you're in Italy things
aren't real French on grayham Frings
things aren't real French things are a
little bit more Amsterdam a little bit
more Haiti you know a little bit more
Kingston you're not getting French on
greyhound people ain't nobody's [ __ ]
with champagne
nobody could spell champagne Greyhound
is where things go off you could catch a
[ __ ] gram you know Greyhound is where
you know some time the driver pull over
[ __ ] leave y'all because he got to
make a court date and that's the kind of
[ __ ] that happens so if you have a
greyhound story because so many of them
came in on my Instagram feeding on my
Facebook feed I'm gonna put together a
full greyhound episode so if you have a
greyhound story that happened to you I
want you to hit the hotline I'm gonna do
the biggest baddest G hound breakdown
that's ever hit America and not to
mention the only one because I've been
on greyhound man nobody took me to here
and drop me off there
I took hound okay I've had to do come up
to me on greyhound and say look but he's
like look man I must he he goes look man
I'm gonna blow you or I'm gonna suck
your dick and I was like dude that's the
same thing bro and you're an idiot and
no because I've been on there man
I've seen to do get on there just fresh
out of prison by two grams of cocaine on
the bus and by the next stop get
arrested and take him back to prison
dude was out of jail he'd been in jail I
think for about 11 years and he was out
of jail for about 28 minutes until we
hit near Vicksburg and then that man
went back
and that's the ham baby you buy a wig
you buy a stepchild you buy whatever you
want so hit the hotline if you got a
Greyhound story nine eight five six six
four nine five zero three and this past
weekend is going to put together the
baddest biggest Greyhound episode ever
I'm gonna try to get a former driver in
here if we can and see what's what
but thank you all for going hound and
you can find some of my my tweets on
Twitter hashtag thanks for going GOI in
hound and you can see that I've been
following him but people expecting
Connor more people are gonna get pissed
off at a Greyhound station everybody's
pissed go to a Greyhound station right
now I'll tell you nine things you'll see
you will see adult men trying to
breastfeed each other you'll see
somebody drinking a can of Similac a
lady and she's fighting with somebody on
the phone you will see somebody cleaning
jelly off of some bar at 100% you'll see
that bro you will also see somebody if
you go outside of the Greyhound look
across the street you'll see somebody
probably lying dead out in front of a
building if you if you go to Greyhound
right now you go in the bathroom you
will see that somebody has changed the
locks and it's probably living in there
if you go to Greyhound right now you
will see that customer the people at the
front desk don't give a [ __ ] about you
they don't care they don't want to be
there they don't give a [ __ ] and you
will see them talk [ __ ] to you no matter
what if you go to Greyhound you will see
you will see a lot of people that have
just gotten out of prison or that have a
newborn and those are the things you'll
see man so check it out man we're gonna
do that greyhound episode that's gonna
be coming up what else is on my mind oh
I went to see that movie
Sherlock gnomes cuz you know I'm a pawn
guy I like a pun you know
I'll get me in anything if a girl writes
a little bit of a pun on her leg a cute
pun right next to that vagine
you know I might be down there reading
that thing and then bam bruh she's you
know she swings those hips and next
thing you know I'm on that low lip-lock
with that little [ __ ] you know with that
you know with that with that little
freaking sweat wallet that they running
you know that sweet pocket bra that uh
that you know that shorty output and and
I love puns so that's what got me man
right there on that pun front what the
[ __ ] was I talking about
I love puns man oh I saw one this
weekend called dough nation do ugh
nation in a tion and they had all kinds
of cookie dough and that was in Tampa so
that's kind of [ __ ] you see in Tampa
donation right right next door to
donation you'll see you know you'll see
like a place where you could give blood
so that's your like it's hard to [ __ ]
sit out there and enjoy your sugary
treat when you know people's dropping
blood right next door oh I'll tell you
what else I saw in Tampa if you haven't
been at this place in Tampa it's called
the castle it's called the castle and
it's downtown it's in an old church and
it's a bar and the vibe in there is
homoerotic and vampires
so do you [ __ ] and if you think I'm
joking go there it feels like Halloween
man it was it was amazing you could be
yourself to have people that have never
seen sunlight in there one guy they'd be
his friends brought a casket in on a
hand truck on a dolly drop that
[ __ ] off boy nine minutes into
the club that that door opened he paid
his $5 cover charge and this dude who
had never seen the light of day was out
in there you know twerking him [ __ ]
showing his work but man they got real
vampires in there you'll be talking to
somebody and you get a hint of [ __ ] a
negative off their breath like damn you
just you're like has everybody been
rare pork chops did everybody order the
lamb no people out there drinking blood
but then when you see a lot of these men
in there that are wild and you know you
see dudes the bathrooms are all gender
neutral because everybody's in costume
everybody in there looks like Marilyn
Manson but with you know a little bit
you know kind of a bunch of chubby
Marilyn Manson's and it's awesome though
if you want to go there they got a cage
where people are whipping people with a
whip you know people in there whipping
people and you know just [ __ ] just
you know and every people got a lot of
robust people in there so everybody got
you grab anything and everything feel
like a titty you know and that's
something I love about you know skinny
people you hug a skinny person you feel
like you doing research you know you
feel like what is that that's a hip
that's a Cossacks what is that
but you hug a thick you know you hug
thick Nick and next thing you know
you're like damn everything feel like a
titty and that's what I that's one thing
I like about people that's a little bit
more rubenesque you know I grew up
stupid I grew up like I like you know I
grew up with our biggest our main food
source was General Mills and different
different cereals in different flavors
of cereals but a lot of people if you
grew up on that meat a potato diet then
you might have a little bit more titty
on you because sometimes people think
just a titty is a titty but I don't
believe that and I wish somebody made
nipples that you could have you know
hook on your skin in other places
because I'll [ __ ] I'll find a new
titty on somebody and you think I won't
I'll find a new titty gang but yeah man
that was awesome or was I talking about
a pun man it was something I was gonna
say to you guys oh and I forgot about it
but yeah man I had a great time down
there in Tampa dinner oh I went and saw
Sherlock gnomes and I didn't like it
that much they did all this cartooning
not a lot of jokes I think they came up
a little bit short so I give Sherlock
gnomes I would say two out of seven
stars even perch like
children I think it was boring I think
even kids they just all that drawing all
that artwork nobody nothing super funny
they had like one funny thing that they
kept doing over and over again and
that's a gnome on a toilet and I've
never known any gnomes you know I have a
friend that's a I got a comedian friend
my boy Nick that's a you know he's
smaller I don't know if he's really a
little person or what the all the
classification is but I've never known a
real gnome you know I've never known a
[ __ ] that did magic and or I guess
they're from Ireland or something I'm
not sure I got a look at some of them
you know some of the fine print on them
but I um they had this dude in my town
when I was growing up and this boy his
name was Tracy and sometimes boys get
girls names because the parents don't
look at their crops right in them you
know when it's born cuz they just met
and I respect parents that do that you
know you just meeting your child and the
first thing you do is look at their
crotch to me that's kind of [ __ ] up
because y'all so you know there's a lot
more to a baby than just you know what
they working with and they had this boy
in our town named Tracy I said they
might have named him before you you know
before they saw got that peak you know
before they started Pervin out on their
own baby for a second in the delivery
room but they also might have just liked
that name because also Dick Tracy was
popular and even if you loved Dick Tracy
he was a famous detective and if you
loved Dick Tracy naming your kid dick
seems insane a lot of people I meet uh
they're they have a family member named
dick and I'm like oh that's absolutely
[ __ ] nuts you're gonna name somebody
dick that's like oh this is my sister
right here vulva you know I'm saying
this my [ __ ] shorty right here areola
my mic's girlfriend you can't name
somebody dick
and people that are named dick if they
don't even they don't it's not even like
a joke to them they're like oh that's a
that's a regular named dick nah brah
that's
a dick man you can't be named after that
you can't meet your [ __ ] you can't
have a [ __ ] friend come over name
[ __ ] bruh you know oh yeah it is Darren
this Tim [ __ ] and Alan no
see how that works it doesn't so if
people's name dick they you got to do
something about that man because it's
alarming to other people but at the time
they had a famous investigator named
Dick Tracy and he was in a famous
investigator and he was beaten that this
is when they had a lot of crazy people
in New York that had wild nicknames like
knuckles and you know flavonoid and all
kind of you know butters McGillicuddy
and you know you know you know Larry to
surgeon or whatever and this dude would
cut off his own thumbs and like sew him
back onto the other fingers and [ __ ]
like that they had real killers out
there and Dick Tracy was the famous
investigator he would hunt them he would
hunt these killers down but they had
this boy in our town him a little Tracy
and he was small man and he would hide
in your [ __ ] you know if he was going on
vacation little Tracy was [ __ ] hot in
your car he'd hide in your mother's
purse if your mom had one of them
[ __ ] big purses you know if she was
going through some [ __ ] or if she you
know you know kept a lot of lunch on her
because a lot of women where I'm from
they keep a lot of lunch on them you
know I grew up in that lunch belt where
if you see somebody you know you in it's
between breakfast and dinner a lot of
times they're not going to eat anywhere
at lunch they got lunch on them so you
could frisk a [ __ ] and fine you
know half a P and J and a couple grams
of uh that cane you feel me but but
anyhow oh if you're on YouTube to the
the power just went out oh there we go
powers back on but anyhow man that was
it man that's what was going on we had a
good time down there went to that castle
saw some vamps a lot of great people
came out and and yeah man they had that
dude
growing up kind of wild what other story
can I tell you guys oh I do want to tell
you about some dates coming up and those
dates are I will be what's good that's
coming up oh I'll be a cluster fest in
San Francisco June 1st 2nd and 3rd and I
don't know what that vibe is gonna be
like I don't know if it's indoors or
outdoors you know so you know just
recognize if you come to see me at that
uh-huh you know it's a big thing it's
probably gonna be fun but it's a you
know it's like a big event I'll be out
there at Cherokee Casino June 9th and
that is in in Oklahoma and people are
asking me will the Sun on the website
well ask them because I don't know I
wish they would put it on there I'll be
at Yuk Yuk's in Calgary and that's June
15th and 16th and I'll be at Imbler
Brewing Company in Bakersfield and I
know Brendan Schaub
from fighter and the kid was just there
this weekend but I'll be there coming up
soon also I got the dark arts tour we're
gonna be popping off some new dates for
you guys I'll announce them next week
because I'm waiting to get the website
finished and I'll get some some logo
which put together this dude on this
website man I mean you know we try and
we try and we trying all right man I'm
gonna be right back I'm gonna get Nikki
and I want to thank grey block pizza and
you know great block pizza man they got
everything if you you know think about
this think about you wake up and you
want some black olives right and maybe
you want that pepperoni maybe you want
that [ __ ] that dirty lawn that dirt a
lawn me because pepperoni could be it
could have anything in it think about it
pepperoni might have that you know it
might have a little bit of thyme a
little bit of thyme you know some
oregano might have a little bit of pork
or chicken it might have a [ __ ] hit
of bubblegum on the back you know might
have that aftertaste that bubblegum
aftertaste but that's pepperoni anything
could be in that [ __ ] so sometime you
want that you want that free buffet you
want them free little buffet medallions
and that's pepperoni you want that black
olives you want pepperoni you want
cheese cuz you ain't no creep you want
real cheese you know I'm saying you want
somebody just spray a cow
and a little bit of salt in your [ __ ]
throat at the same time and that's what
you get a great block pizza you get
those mixes they got all kinds of fancy
pizza the Bella goat the that I think
they got the dr. Zhivago you know I'm
making some of those up because I don't
see my menu isn't here at the moment but
they got everything great block pizza
18:11 Pico Boulevard get that hitter all
right man I'll be right back with Nick
in the studio we're gonna do news we're
gonna go to some calls we're gonna have
oh dude I had a dream about Kevin Bacon
speaking of pepperoni how to dream up
Kevin Bacon bro and I was thinking about
this so Kevin Bacon okay first of all
named bacon Huey can you can you imagine
growing up with the name bacon as your
last name and thinking that you have a
chance to make it in Hollywood like his
journey had to be harder than anybody's
then who who else you you know you know
I'm saying we're like say your name's
Susan carne asada
[ __ ] you ain't gonna be in MacGyver you
know you ain't gonna be in Dunkirk
probably if you're if your name is um
Larry uh pork on local brah Larry
chicken crazy Larry crazy chicken you're
not gonna get it can you imagine saying
my last name is a meat and I'm still
gonna take life to the next level and
that challenge I mean that's new you
don't see that you don't see that you
know you can you even imagine can you
even imagine that I can't what if your
name is Debbie pork what if your name is
or [ __ ] up you know Sergio veal
medallions [ __ ] you lucky to
work at the bank but Kevin Bacon said
nah I got this you know what if your
name is [ __ ] Dorothy pork chop could
you imagine what would you probably stay
at home oh I wouldn't be a brain
Eve enough to go out there with a meet
name and take that meat to the next
level
he's brave man maybe you work at a
kennel
you know what if your name is uh you
know Randy beef jerky [ __ ] you
lucky to work at a Chevron maybe in your
later years you get some junior
associate work at a kennel or at a
garage but GE the odds are you making it
come on man you can do that dude to be
in the front lines and be a meat say man
my name is Kevin Bacon and then overcome
the odds gang bruh and he gets that he
gets that game an honor that man told a
damn I'm dead because if I had a meet
name if I had a if my name was uh you
know Raphael Cheech our honest or armed
or if my name was a Willie shrimp
[ __ ] I'll probably be working
about a YMCA volunteering we'll be right
back with the news and with some of you
guys's calls and for the first time with
our producer that's gonna be working
here in the second half of the show he's
not in here the first half that's us
that's our time and I want to thank
everybody that came out man people came
out and I know like look the club's sold
VIP meet-and-greet tickets I didn't do
that I want to let you guys know the
club did that it's just the way their
ticket program is set up so I like to
meet everybody at the end of the shows
so if you left early and you thought I
didn't get to meet you that wasn't on me
you know because then we had to do
something special for the meet-and-greet
people because they paid extra but I'm
not doing that [ __ ] so in the future man
will meet everybody and I'll be out
there and come enjoy yourselves you know
and so if you felt like um you know if
you felt slighted by that I'm sorry I
didn't set that up they so they did all
the ticketing and that was just how
their system was but if you felt
slighted let me know and I'll make it up
to you and I come back
I promise you that I will be right back
in literally five seconds we're gonna do
voicemails and news first that's the
voice of Nick Davis right there and and
Nick were you from Nick I'm from La
Crosse Wisconsin oh wow man yeah Midwest
and I spent eight years in Minneapolis
and worked for what nut crime nope nope
went to school there and okay then yep
yep worked there for a while and then I
migrated out west
what brought you out west man what was
it I just love the comedy scene
podcasting I feel like it's a really
growing medium and there's a ton of
opportunity here and people like you
Corolla Rogen like have grown
independent projects and I think there's
a ton of opportunity with that and just
want to be a part of it and yeah man I'm
well I'm and I met Nick at Corolla and
we did some work in the past and then
he's come in as just as a lifesaver and
gotten gotten us you know to the point
where we can have guests and like
helping us with all the technical side
of things and man I can't I really can't
thank you enough man oh no problem it's
been a blast especially seeing your
podcast grow and now you're having
guests in Jay morte Fletcher excited to
see who you're gonna have next yeah me
too man ice I know Bobby Lee said he
wanted to come in but I also wanna be
able to get like just you know they had
this Ober driver that used to be on some
dust I know that I met recently so I
think I want to try to you know see you
know what that's like I guess part of my
fear is just that you know I guess it's
not a fear of I guess the you know that
the listeners will I guess think that
that kind of [ __ ] isn't cool you know I
think they could hear you talk to anyone
I mean just like the guy who you met at
the DMV come in he doesn't have much of
a Twitter following but I think I've
already enjoyed the interview dude at
the DMV that day man he had about six
followers literally when I met that dude
on even steven he had nobody's more
popular than the DMV that day but I
think we needed up coming into the stew
into the you know first time I ever had
a guest not here but that he was on some
dusters he wasn't doing well and he
might have passed and he hasn't
responded to a text in probably about
three months well hope he's alright yeah
we'll see man or hope he's in heaven
you know sometimes I mean being out here
ain't for everybody but yeah we got some
calls and we got I'm going to see [ __ ]
blockers tonight so you know I got to
take a little date to the sea blockers
and so I'm gonna go do that and two of
my friends actually wrote that film and
uh and it got it's been edited a ton
since they sold it but they wrote it my
friends Jim and Brian Kehoe and I
couldn't be more proud to know them and
we're trying to work on a project
together now to go out and sell and
based on my neighborhood that I grew up
in so I'm pretty excited about that yeah
that sounds like a blast it's pretty
cool man so keep your fingers crossed
and keep us in in your in your in your
good spirit vibes all right man let's
crack into some stuff Nick what uh well
what did I miss well I was out of town
there's a lot of news let's see in Tempe
mom was arrested after police say her
child ate mac and cheese made with THC
butter okay a lien Elena buried limpert
25 was booked on one count of child
abuse the Department of Child Safety was
notified by someone in limp Hertz home
that her almost 2 year old daughter had
adjusted THC butter while eating
macaroni and cheese with her father
during that time neither parent took the
child to immediate emergency care and
even joked about the effects that was
having on the child and later put her in
the pool - shocker out of the hi to him
well I mean I don't know who wrote the
thing you know and that's okay
like obviously you can't be giving the
children drugs you know and that is also
something you'll see on greyhound
sometimes but you cannot be giving the
children drugs you know you can't do it
I mean because here's the thing it's
obvious whatever neighborhood that kid
is in they're probably gonna find drugs
eventually you know she can't start them
off that early by giving them drugs and
you it's not fair to hide a drug and
something that to a kid is already a
drug macaroni and cheese is a [ __ ]
drug I was thinking the same thing man
yeah those carbs dude when you're a kid
do macaroni and cheese you see that
bright yellow you see somebody else just
that spoon comes out of that pot and
that big heaping just mound a hot gooey
just fun
sitting on that [ __ ] spoon and it
hits that bowl
that's opium to up to a maybe not to a
two-year over two three four five year
old that's opioids you know that's that
uh suboxone I mean that stuff that's
everything that's that cheesy heroin so
you get that man as a child so it's
wrong you know these people out there
doing that kind of stuff with the kids
now I understand putting the child and
holding the child in the pool maybe
after thinking that they're gonna be
able to you know help the kid out and I
don't know how tough the two-year-old is
you know if the two-year-olds already
been [ __ ] yeah I mean no I think a
Tirol can't be partying or doing
anything like that where they're gonna
have built up any tolerance to this kind
of stuff hopefully now yeah so I think
yes that's unfortunate man what else we
got
let's see after I know you mentioned a
little bit about Connors antics throwing
a hand truck through a bus at Barclays
Center yeah
as a result Connor McGregor was charged
with three counts of criminal mischief
two counts of assault one count of
attempted assault and five counts of
menacing and one count of reckless
endangerment
he's currently out on $50,000 bond and
is back in Ireland awaiting his June
court date however khabib nurmagomedov
did end up winning the undisputed
hundred fifty five pound title and this
these antics only heightened their
potential matchup later this year and it
makes you wonder madami Connor is I mean
he walks through he beasties walks to
the beat of his own drum you think that
definitely I think he's gotten to such a
point of success he's uh he feel he
literally feels invincible like none of
he can do anything he wants and he's
acting as such did you feel like it was
an my first thought was is this an ego
thing like is he feeling left out
because you know I mean he was a that
was a crescendo of media attention with
him and the mayweather fight and then
it's really you know you can't stay at
that level forever and that's a drug and
so do you uh do you think that was it or
did you think something else happened
and that's what set him off I definitely
think he was it was retaliation because
khabib team had cornered and confronted
his
teammate and unfriend Artem Loeb of
earlier in the week at Barclays so it
was retaliation because of that but I
think like you're saying he was he's
looking for any excuse to pop himself
into the back into the limelight so sure
he's defending his friend but he did it
in the most demonstrative way possible
and made headlines yeah that's true man
he really stole the weekend and he
probably I mean do you think more people
bought the pay-per-view after I
definitely think so I do I think it just
brought the card this weekend
more into the public consciousness
people were seeing because every Conor
McGregor headline about his antics also
included information about the fight
this weekend yeah people want to have
been in CNN and deadlines and Hollywood
Reporter like it was yeah that's a good
point suddenly they're you want to just
get involved you want to see what's
going on and I'm gonna break down one of
the fights coming up this on this
weekend's card coming up on this
upcoming weekends card and we'll get
into that a little bit more at another
time let's get to some calls man cuz I
got a UH I want to see this film tonight
this [ __ ] blockers I'm going to watch
whereas the preview say pop blockers no
they say yeah cuz I can't say [ __ ] on
there yeah too bad they can't say caught
alright let's see do you have one you
want to play first or sure I just just
hit that line alright here we go
here is hunter alright what's up the Oh
Jan gang man this is your boy hunter
down in Memphis Tennessee
Oh hunter man and that's a you know a
lot of people in some areas have names
that are activities hunter they had this
bull when I was growing up name climber
Simpson and climber you know that's
something slider you know a lot of
people in Tennessee and different rural
areas will have names that are
activities jumper you know some people
have some piece of clothing but where
I'm from that was a name or whether you
know we've talked about that before
stormy rainy dusty those are all names
so sometimes people will have more
active names but hunter thank you for
calling what's up man
and I had a quick question for you man
my body goes down to MTSU we like to mix
drugs a little bit and we have mixed
some LSD one night and some coke and
tamale and some other things that uh I
was just wondering my buddy had a batch
trip on it we went to a club and
Illinois so you mixed what do you say
Molly coke LSD LSD and some other drugs
we'll look dude let me tell you this man
and you know this I'm sure are certainly
your heart does and your central nervous
system there aren't that many more drugs
I mean how many you thrown any more
ingredients man you [ __ ] running on
detergent you know saying what are you
you know of a saying you all damn you
might as well [ __ ] do the dishes do
you ain't party it anymore
you know I'm saying after so many
different drugs you're not you're not
doing drugs anymore do you about to
[ __ ] get a job you know mop and
service stations dude you've got to get
a job you know you're about to get a job
working for um Todd pods so I think I
[ __ ] I can't even imagine mixing that
many things man but you guys were out
there let's hear more audio Eve and it
got wild and I enjoyed it you know I was
pressing into that Mexican chicks love
and pain all over myself you know
shirtless and this is in colder weather
back code so you know I just wanted your
thoughts on mixing drugs like that and
any crazy stories you had thanks man you
bet man hundred thank you for calling
dude yeah mixing drugs I mean when I was
young age to do trolling tripping and
rolling and that was an easy one you
know but then one time I remember you
know I grew up in the bad acid belt so a
lot of bad acid would come through and
then next thing you know everybody would
shave their legs you know the next week
men and women you're like what the [ __ ]
happened you know it just something you
know it would leave that little you know
just leave that little uh you know some
little it would just shrimp up your
genetics so you know you just kind of
swirled in a little bit and everybody
would do something weird after everybody
would shave off their eyebrows you know
or you know armor one time some bad acid
came
threw and a couple people's dads started
wearing eye patches after that and you
knew who had done the acid because you
knew you know the next week everybody's
[ __ ] you know out there just pirate
and just freelancing and I remember one
time this girl was that gals name man
Christy Thicke Christy they called her
because she was exactly as advertised
and she had him and you could find a
titty anywhere on her you know you could
[ __ ] she just felt like about 90
titties you know in a tight shirt and
she she we were at a party and we had
this groupies to do some acid with and
you know she took a couple hits of
something and and then she got scared
she got locked in a room you know she
wanted to be in there and we didn't lock
her in I don't think necessarily you
know but she stayed in there and we
stayed outside and people were going
there and poor kind of warm water on her
you know and she you know was it right
was it wrong who knows I mean everybody
in the whole [ __ ] house was on LSD so
it's not like you know we could have
thought we were making tea we could have
thought we were making soup you know we
could have thought we was making human
soup I don't [ __ ] know but I remember
going into a room high on LSD we're all
scared thinking there's like a bear in
there and it's just that Kristi in there
and the lights are out and she just see
her eyes and because when somebody's on
acid bro their eyes are running about 45
watts each so you just see her in the
distance we would go over there and just
pour a little bit of warm water out of a
cooking bucket cooking pail you know
just like a macaroni pail and I don't
know she was drinking it or just letting
it splash on her back or whatever but
that was something that got a little bit
weird one time we had this boy named
Joseph at a party one time and he
started he's like let's play
hide-and-go-seek and then he started
counting and ran off to hide at the same
time and he was on LSD and never [ __ ]
saw that dude again so and part of the
problem was he had taken on both
responsibilities of the game so if
everybody anybody who was thinking oh
I'll play hide-and-go-seek on acid seems
like fun but suddenly when Joseph's
counting
and running to hide he's [ __ ] himself
so easy you know who knows what he
counted to maybe a hundred makes you
know he gets to a hundred but he's
hiding somewhere and maybe that's when
he starts looking for himself and who
knows what happened to him could ended
up homeless probably in a I would guess
honestly dude down in Tampa he could be
the mayor now
but thanks for calling hunter man we
used to mix him you know I remember just
sometimes uh it got tougher for me to
mix him when I got older because I would
be doing drugs by myself and you know
you don't have you got to have that
sidekick you got to have that shotgun
you know you got to have you get you
gotta have somebody to hold Jass cheeks
open and make sure you know that you
know that you you know that you're
keeping your Panama Canal clean you got
to have a sidekick
let's take another call all right this
is from Joe he's got an interesting
quandary what I feel this is Joe from
Pennsylvania Pittsburgh
James Bond would say it and I apologize
but I'm calling because I need some help
from you or maybe some other caller out
there that that has some advice for me
so this girl I know she's 17 and she's
trying to persuade me with her dark arts
you know what I mean oh yeah that kid
he's been real persistent with it you
know restaurant me get that Italian
sausage for me you know an event if
you're at out anyways I'm twenty thirty
so you know that's against the law
pretty much and you know I get weird
even like Texas this girl back from God
you know it's just weird you know it's
all weird and should I wait which one's
gonna wait should I wait till she's 18
or should I just block her I don't know
what to do you know it seems kind of
strange to me I want to know what you
would do or what one of the other colors
will do and that's a good question man
that's a good question and we will we
will we'll put that out to the callers
I mean I'll tell you this if you're
James Franco you could make movies and
be a movie star and you know I know they
had a story came out a while back about
him you know running at some 17-year old
and uh so you know if you move to
Hollywood you'll probably be okay you
could probably have a decent career you
know this is you know this really is
sex-offender country out here but where
you are
I mean it's risky I mean here's one
thing you didn't hear I didn't hear you
say that you love this girl you know I
didn't hear you say you're in love with
her I feel that temptation though and
the temptation is natural you know
that's like the Sun and the moon looking
for each other people always think if
the Sun and the moon found each other
that they would you know the earth would
blow up or something dude no they would
[ __ ] that's what would happen and that's
all that's going on out there it's just
the solar system is just a bunch of big
balls trying to [ __ ] each other and
gravity's keeping them away from each
other but you didn't say you're in love
with this girl saw you know the rules is
the rules you know you could try to look
and get some strange look man it when I
wasn't when I was 20 years old in
college I dated a girl that was 17 she
was in high school and we were in love
you know and her parents were okay with
it and I was okay with it and you know I
wasn't a good boyfriend probably you
know because I was a shady college kid
but but you know I was just probably
like most other boyfriends that were
doing you know caught up in there so
it's wild man it's risky you know Nick
what do you think I think first of all
he definitely shouldn't announce that
he's thinking about doing it on a
national podcast that was mistake number
one but I sense he already has done that
I definitely think he should just wait
it out we have weighed out the
temptation brother it's someplace less
than a year could be a month could be
just a couple months I think you can do
it man
yeah maybe make a little fun time clock
on your phone or something you know get
one of those dog countdown apps you know
and title it you know you know Cheryl or
whatever the lady's name is and just you
know she'll be 17 and
because look that that's one thing is
tough out there these days the
temptation the accessibility you know
you would think that a lot of these
social media apps wouldn't have the
ability for people of different ages
really to interact it's kind of kind of
it's it it could be super inappropriate
you know like I mean I get it it's
natural in a lot of look man when I was
in when I was in high school all the hot
girls that were 18 or seniors they all
dated guys in college you know a lot of
that's natural I mean where it comes in
I mean you getting into 23 she's 17
looking at six years I mean what do you
think Nick I liked your idea of the
countdown clock maybe you could even
have like some type of like Nativity
calendar as you count down to this for
Christmas he could have a little little
calendar with like chocolates in it and
every day just eat the chocolate and
he's one step closer that's good get a
little gum put a little gum you know get
one of those um you know the calendars
like they had on Bad Santa like that
little chubby boy and he got them
candies every time and get closer how to
chocolate you know I put a [ __ ]
couple of Milk Duds and a hole in your
wall and reach for one of them [ __ ]
everyday you make it treat yourself you
know treat yourself an honor this lady
and if and if you're not willing to do
all that then at least you know it's not
love you're trying to get some strange
do it I would turn I would just look the
other way and I would block her because
you're gonna be tempted look man you
[ __ ] with temptation temptation is a
barber shop and if you hang out in a
barber shop you're gonna get a haircut
dude and I don't want your next call to
be coming from jail you know or unless
you want to go meat or Pam I mean look
you guys put in a lot of work if you
don't care that much man I would maybe
just let it rest I just think that's the
safest thing because a lot of the ladies
out there they just run you know and
their parents could be looking for a
lawsuit next thing you know you know you
pay them for their Honda Civic and all
of this [ __ ] so anything could happen
man but if anybody else has a response
today you can hit the hotline nine eight
five six six four nine five zero three
and we will will offer him up some
suggestions what else we got let's see
we have a call from Kristin she has a
funny baby
story okay there we go yeah this is
christening this is calling us
adventures in babysitting okay thank you
for calling Kristen I appreciate it
onward high school I worked with the
family for like a few years and if they
had three kids in the middle little
girls I was between each three or four
when day came and sat on my lap and
butterflies most kids do you just gave
me a hug and a kiss but then point-blank
asked me why are you brown and mind you
I'm black so I kind of caught me by
surprise but I just ended up telling her
like hey you know I looked like my
family and my mom and dad er you know of
the shades of brown and so I look kind
of like them and that didn't really seem
to satisfy her she actually just asked
me why I don't understand why you don't
look like us I want you to look like me
my family why don't you look like that
so then I told her that you know God
made everyone different he you know
likes to use all the different colors of
the rainbow mixed up a little bit that
also didn't satisfy her so I finally
ended up just telling her it's because I
drank a lot of chocolate milk when I was
little and that seemed to work did she
stop asking after that but a couple
weeks afterwards she went to school or
something and she said I made new
friends one Lim's name is Daniel and he
drank a lot of chocolate mocha that
Tiffany would start kind of wondering
what eat notice the difference of
cultures are different people know the
thing that people look different than
you that's a great question I appreciate
that call you know I'll tell you this I
remember I remember when I I went to
South Africa actually when I was in
college I went as a student and I got
there and they're worse and of you know
it's predominantly black and I had never
seen so many black people at one time or
african-american these people actually
African people so but people have darker
skin you know and it here was ago here
was a wild thought that I remember it
went into my head I was like wow
if I ever go to heaven most of the
people in heaven will be different
ethnicities and I've never thought that
I had not wanted to think it there was
just this basic thought in my head that
that heaven you know I just went to
church most of people in my church were
white so it just I thought of when I
thought of heaven I thought a basically
the people in my church in you know
living in a cloud or living in a you
know I just thought of it as probably
not super diverse and not like certain
people weren't allowed or black if you
weren't allowed our Asian people warned
Allah I just didn't there wasn't enough
connotation in my history in my
existence in my life for me to see that
it could be real and and so I remember
the first when I went to South Africa
just being like it just I was like wow
man most of in heaven
things will be extremely diverse and if
anything white people will be the
minority and it it that was kind of one
of the first times I think not that I
realized that people had different
colors of skin because you know I grew
up from the jump I was on like school
bus with the black kids and you know we
were all living in the poor part of town
so you know I used to be in this group
called NFL when I was in middle school
and it was stood for [ __ ] for life you
know I didn't name the group but I was
only white guy in it and there was just
the kids I ran with you know it was
probably the kids I felt most
comfortable with and the truth is I've
found a lot of white people like black
culture is extremely fascinating you
know it's there's a lot of amazing music
comes out of black clothes a lot amazing
art a lot of amazing I mean these kids
are the best athletes these kids were
you know they were it was almost like
they were these these jewels sometimes
in some ways that other people didn't
know about you know that like I was like
what doesn't you know it didn't seem
right that they didn't have more
because they had so many talents but so
I guess I didn't notice it as much
because it was more my everyday
existence growing up but that was a
moment that I had when I was like wow a
lot of the earth a lot of the world
because I went straight from America to
South Africa so there wasn't I hadn't
traveled a bunch of places I probably
only been in about four states before
that and they were all in the south and
and I just had never seen a place where
the predominant of the population was
different than white and so it just
shook me it was a good man in an
afterlife it will be really diverse and
and that started to give me a wider view
of of the world I think of just of race
anyhow for sure but look man some places
I find these days that chocolate milk
thing is funny I'm trying to think what
I thought do you have any thoughts like
that Nick do you think just in a similar
fashion I definitely thought chocolate
milk only came from brown cows so yeah I
feel like that logic is it's pretty
solid to be honest yeah from a kid I
think that is solid you know that like
yeah chocolate milk came from brown cows
that makes sense I thought that you know
certain maybe uh I thought that all cows
I remember could make steaks and like I
guess some of them can't I did not know
that yeah and I thumped dairy country oh
I thought all cows can make milk oh and
it's only you know female cows and
obviously there's the old joke you know
you don't want to drink the milk from
the male cows but I thought that all
cows can make milk and I can all cows
make meat yes they can yes there are a
lot of dairy cows aren't necessarily
used as we've cattle but you definitely
could mm-hmm-hmm and my thing I remember
one time thinking are fish you know I
asked a waiter one time if the fish was
male or female you know I got a bit of
mahi-mahi and he didn't know and I don't
think anybody [ __ ] knows so if you
want to find a general gender-neutral
species where shit's working out for
them that's probably fish but I
appreciate that call man I am
you know I think we got some stuff
people can hit the hotline right yeah
definitely yeah Colin leave some
messages I think we've got some stuff
also we had a call that came in for this
past weekend for the contest every month
if you have something that happened to
you this weekend it was awesome or it
wasn't awesome hit the hotline leave us
a voicemail nine eight five six six four
nine five zero three so we can make you
guys a part of the experience and and
just let us know if your weekend was
good or bad just give it to us I'll try
to make it you know 60 seconds or less
and each month we got one of these
correctional blue t-shirts then we're
gonna give out say this past weekend
we'll send you one and they had a
gentleman that won one last month and we
saw him a Senate to him but it's just
been a wild time but I want to thank you
guys for your support thank you guys for
listening we're gonna go out on Spencer
Jacob growl we may have another episode
this week we're gonna try to get some
guests I'm gonna I'm gonna be shooting a
television pilot down in Louisiana back
in my hometown so I'm really excited
about that and just feeling pretty
grateful for the opportunity but yeah I
hope you guys a good man I hope
everybody's doing okay you know and if
you're not if you need something hit the
hotline let us know you know if there's
a way that we can help out or do some
outreach or something we'll try you know
we're slowly starting to put a little
team together here and it's exciting and
it feels good you got any closing
thoughts on it just onward onward man I
like it that sounds good man we'll see
you guys very soon
[Music]
mrs. Spencer Jacob growl
be good to yourselves guys you probably
deserve it you know that love you and
thank you so much man
[Music]
I gotta go see this [ __ ] blockers
we all die
celebrate our days